NARRATOR: From Welsh girl
from an unknown fly speck
of an island to supermodel.
Darling, hello.
I'm Michael.
You look like you're in hell.
I'm sorry.
You can see it in
your eyes, darling.
And [inaudible] a camera.
[inaudible]
Hold it, let me drag you away.
NARRATOR: In the end, a defining
cultural icon of our times.
As ageless art director
of American "Vogue,"
she is fashion's version
of a literary giant.
I've got to admit, I've had some
butterflies about all of this.
Oh, no.
You mean about
fashion generally.
Well, that's a separate issue.
No, I'm talking about
meeting Grace Coddington,
because it's like meeting any
great leader in their field.
Hey, it's like--
- Oh, no.
NARRATOR: --when I meet
one of the great Taliban--
No, no, no, I'm not that.
When I meet a great
Taliban commander,
I get a little bit nervous--
- Well--
--or a four-star general.
--yeah, I would be too.
It's the same.
You know, I mean, you
are Grace Coddington.
I mean, how do you carry that?
Forget "Vogue" and forget--
Don't ask me
questions like that.
[inaudible]
Well, tell me about
fashion, all right?
I'm a stranger in
a strange land.
I've been here a week.
I think I know less
than when I arrived.
Probably, yeah.
It's confusing.
Does any of this
thing have any meaning?
I think we're all more
lost than we were before.
We're at a very strange moment
in fashion at the moment.
Has fashion ever been
under such assault,
if I may use that word, before?
Because it's coming
from you and me--
I think every so often
it is, and it does,
and one has to ask the question.
I can't remember it being in
such a kind of strange place.
And it's a cultural thing.
It's not just the fashion thing.
So all this is
happening, because
of all the different things
that are happening in the world.
To wear clothes that are
extreme and very fashiony
doesn't feel right
now, because it's not
that moment in the
political situation
or the cultural situation.
Obviously, it affects fashion.
It does.
Fashion's not like
a little island.
Well, this is precisely one of
the burning questions I've had
is about that interface between
history or culture and fashion.
Right now we live in a
relatively dark political age--
Yeah.
--where Paris can blow
up at any moment, Brussels
can blow up at any moment.
Fashion can offer
us an escape or it
can offer us an expression of
that mood or it can offer us--
It should offer
all those things.
--a reflection.
Yeah.
And it does.
It does?
And what we're seeing
now is exactly that.
It's a reflection of
all the insecurities
and the darkness and all
those different things
that you mentioned.
You really think it is, yeah?
Yeah, I do.
I do.
Because that's been
a little pet theory.
As a outsider, it's nothing.
No, you get it, even
though you're not really
a fashion person, you know.
Don't you love
the way she looked
at me when she said that?
Oh, my god.